[Música]
algunos de ustedes puede decir soy un
proyecto terminado
ya está no me voy a modificar más no voy
a cambiar en nada no tengo nada que
aprender ya estoy listo
es imposible
vivimos modificando nos
vimos a cada instante rediseñando nos
descubriéndonos transformando nos
interior y exteriormente
ayer hice una pequeña transformación en
mi exterior e hice mi primer tatuaje
rompiendo quizás muchas barreras
internas también no sé si sabrán pero en
la antigüedad el pueblo hebreo comenzó a
disminuir las leyes de la esclavitud
tal es así que si un esclavo decidía
quedarse con su amo se le hacía una
pequeña marca en la oreja algo parecido
a esto que simboliza sé que dejó de lado
la libertad
claro los símbolos y las marcas no no
tienen el mismo significado para unos
que para otros lo que sin lugar a dudas
podemos decir es la fuerza que tienen
los símbolos también sabemos lo terrible
que puede pasar cuando marcamos a
alguien por considerarlo diferente pero
es innegable la fuerza de los símbolos y
la fuerza del cuerpo para expresar estos
símbolos
porque es esto
cada vez más entendemos que todo lo que
le adjudica vamos al poder de la mente
en el cerebro no ocurre solamente en el
cerebro ocurre a través de todo el
cuerpo
es más el cuerpo en el espacio y en
relación con nosotros
el cuerpo entonces es una herramienta de
aprendizaje en casi todas las culturas
se demuestra que aprendemos con los
números contando con los dedos
también cuando tomamos nota por ejemplo
estamos creando dos recuerdos uno
auditivo y otro motriz que hace que
después
recordemos más fácil el acontecimiento y
en casi todas las escuelas la educación
física es obligatoria o común
sabemos cada vez más que el cuerpo es
una herramienta de aprendizaje pero
también una herramienta de
experimentación y de acción
entonces
si sabemos que el cuerpo es de
aprendizaje el espacio donde se
desarrolla esa actividad
es determinante el urbanista jungle nos
va a hablar de la importancia de las
escalas humanas cuando caminamos en un
contexto como este por ejemplo
es muy fácil que nos sintamos como
incómodos oa velocidades que no son las
humanas es fácil que necesitemos un
contexto por lo menos esta persona que
bien que le vendrían unos árboles que
marquen al menos un espacio que tenga
relación con nuestras proporciones
el espacio es determinante y las
distancias también lo son y todos los
sabemos inconscientemente sabemos que no
es lo mismo la distancia íntima que la
distancia social que podemos tener con
desconocidos en la calle o una distancia
pública como la que estamos teniendo en
este momento y esta es la distancia
adecuada para decirle a mi familia que
me hice un tatuaje
mi tatuaje dice habitar
habitar
es el tiempo
que me dedico a estar
en un lugar
probablemente con otras personas
habitar es el tiempo
que me dedico a observar a
interrelacionar me con otros a
pertenecer a un grupo y su interrelación
con el espacio también
cuando habitó transformó un lugar cuando
estamos en un lugar todos lo estamos
transformando
también cuando lo transformó me apropio
es decir cuando hábito no es algo
pasajero es que lo hago mío al lugar
el lugar me pertenece yo pertenezco al
lugar me identifico con un espacio con
una casa con una calle con un barrio
lo hago parte de mi identidad mi ciudad
es parte de mi identidad
lo que sin duda sabemos que habitar no
es un resultado no es listo ya vite
eso hábito ahora pero que viene también
de un proceso y va a tener una
continuidad
no es instantáneo no es un resultado
y eso también es los desafíos que tiene
el urbanismo entender las ciudades los
espacios públicos como procesos no solo
como resultados y como procesos
colectivos
porque colectivos porque somos seres
sociales somos seres gregarios nos
necesitamos agregar nos
no hace falta pensar
en toda la cantidad de bichos sociales
que andan dando vuelta piensen en
ustedes como propios bichos sociales que
son cuando la noche apremia cuando el
trabajo cansa en la rutina el estrés del
estudio cuando la vida merece ser
celebrada
qué es lo que hacemos
bueno una respuesta puede ser tomar
cerveza pero cuando vamos a tomar
cerveza a dónde vamos y qué es lo que
más nos gusta cuando vamos a un bar
cuando salimos a caminar a la calle
cuando vamos a tomar mate al parque
lo que más nos gusta a los seres humanos
es el encuentro con otras personas es
ver gente
sang él también habla de que los
estímulos efímeros incluso de baja
intensidad entre las personas hacen que
se produzcan posiblemente y seguramente
más encuentros casuales y esto lo que
hace es que se produzcan después más
encuentros íntimos entonces necesitamos
esta cantidad de encuentros para tener
ciudades vibrantes y vitales pero por
supuesto que
también tenemos conflictos no con el
habitar colectivo
y
el cuerpo ese aprendizaje el espacio ese
aprendizaje y el encuentro con el otro
la mirada con el otro también me
determina también me configura a mí como
persona como individuo y en mí y como
proceso
y todos esos conflictos y la mirada con
el otro se da en el espacio público como
arena de encuentro
como mujer
quizás las primeras palabras sexuales
que hayan recibido en mi vida hayan sido
de un desconocido cuando era niña una
persona adulta en una calle de noche eso
también es aprendizaje aprendizaje
corporal y en el espacio público
claro sabemos que hay muchos tipos de
conflictos y que el espacio no va a
resolver todo sin embargo podemos
diseñar procesos para mejores encuentros
pueden planificarse los procesos también
y tenemos que encontrarnos en buenos
lugares y los lugares también van a
condicionar qué tipo de encuentro vamos
a tener
no es lo mismo por ejemplo caminar por
una vereda que por otra
cuando caminamos en una vida interesante
con fachadas de colores con actividades
con intercambio entre el adentro y el
afuera no es lo mismo que cuando
caminamos por un borde duro donde no hay
nada no hay actividad no hay lo que se
llama james echoes o la mirada del otro
no los ojos a la calle y eso hace que
nos sintamos de una manera o de otra y
probablemente nos guste mucho más
caminar por estos espacios que por los
otros y dejemos de caminar por los otros
entonces al dejar de caminar al tener
esa sensación de inseguridad
probablemente producimos más inseguridad
real en el espacio
la mirada del otro el encuentro el
proceso puede planificarse sobre todo y
necesitamos buenos lugares para hacer
esto
para generar buenos lugares necesitamos
por supuesto muchos conocimientos
técnicos y para resolver los problemas
de las ciudades necesitamos un montón de
conocimientos técnicos por ejemplo
podemos contar qué
a menor intensidad de tráfico en una
calle se generan más cruces peatonales
entre una vereda de otra y en el barrio
se pueden detectar mayor cantidad de
redes mayor cantidad de amigos
también podemos hablar de la de la
dificultad o
el peligro que puede causar simplemente
porque aumentemos de 30 kilómetros por
hora a 50 kilómetros por hora la
velocidad de un automóvil
les puedo contar que por ejemplo si
diseñamos los espacios públicos solo con
canchas de fútbol el 80% o 90% de su uso
va a ser solo por hombres
en cambio ponemos actividades opcionales
dentro de ese espacio devolvemos la
diversidad a ese espacio y también las
personas pasan más tiempo en el espacio
hay más cosas para hacer y al pasar las
personas más tiempo en el espacio lo
habitamos lo transformamos y además nos
gusta ver más personas con lo cual al
poner actividades opcionales ponemos
mejor el espacio público hacemos entre
todos mejor el espacio público pero
muchos saberes son técnicos y es
necesario con urgencia abrirlos
democratizar los expandir todos los
datos que tengamos pero muchos otros
problemáticas no van a ser resueltas
solamente por técnicos
necesitamos la inteligencia colectiva
para esto cuando sabemos que tenemos que
ir urgente hacia un modelo de movilidad
sustentable o que los cambios climáticos
son productos de nuestros consumos
desmedidos estos no hay técnicos que lo
puedan resolver lo tenemos que resolver
en conjunto
no se desanimen hay muchas veces que
hemos demostrado ser mucho más
eficientes en conjunto que solos
probablemente si en el 2007 les hubiera
dicho porque modelo de negocio invertir
si un estudio de especialistas con
títulos bien pagos trabajando full time
para escribir una enciclopedia
o una red descentralizada de voluntarios
que pueden evitarse unos a otros
probablemente todos los que estamos acá
hubiéramos perdió mucha plata
invirtiendo la encarta y no hubiéramos
invertido nada en wikipedia con lo cual
hemos demostrado que para algunos
conflictos para algunas problemáticas
somos mejores resolviendo en conjunto
tenemos capacidades gregarias y este es
el proyecto que trabajamos
es pensar cómo se pueden combinar los
conocimientos técnicos y los saberes
comunes los saberes de todos los
ciudadanos
y desarrollar nuestras capacidades
gregarias
necesitamos agregar nos para resolver
nuestros problemas resolver en conjunto
requiere poner en práctica nuestra
capacidad de inteligencia colectiva lo
primero que tenemos que hacer para esto
el primer paso es reconocernos
reconocernos cada uno de nosotros saber
que tenemos conocimientos diferentes y
experiencias diferentes y valorizar las
todas y ponerlas en horizontal compartir
nuestros conocimientos y crear
objetivos y soluciones para problemas
que tenemos en común
materializar lo realizaron nuestras
nuestros resultados colectivos a partir
de nuestras problemáticas colectivas
cuando empecé a estudiar la arquitectura
sabía que mi lado era por el lado de
urbanismo pero a veces me preguntaba
urbanismo no es la arquitectura de la
ciudad
cuando pienso en un espacio diseñado
bonito como resultado a ese dios y esa
arquitectura después me acuerdo la
cantidad de recuerdos que hay en ese
espacio de historias de procesos de
anécdotas la cantidad de actores que
intervienen la cantidad de conflictos
que se dan en el espacio y ahí me
acuerdo porque estudié lo que estudie
porque estudio gestión de ciudades y
porque me dedico a través de proyecto a
crear ya a involucrar ciudadanos para
resolver los conflictos que tenemos en
común y alimentar nuestra inteligencia
colectiva
los invito a que habiten en sus ciudades
a que piensen que calidad de espacios
públicos para el encuentro estamos
diseñando estamos realizando no hace
falta que sean diseñadores con solo
pensar en este espacio me puedo enamorar
es suficiente para pensar un buen
espacio
lo que más me apasionan de las ciudades
es que nadie puede decir
yo hago una ciudad por mi cuenta
la ciudad es un proceso colectivo
gregario el primer impulso
nosotros para crear ciudades es gregario
por eso una vez más los invito seres
gregarios la ciudad es suya
[Aplausos]